Our Heroes they're criminals that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now a fascinating survey released last
week got very little attention but given
the latest news out of crime ridden New
York it's worth revisiting
according to the CBS yougov poll 72
percent of Americans think the country
is out of control
the reasons they think it's out of
control range from the overall state of
politics at 88 to the economy at 85
percent with 75 percent citing culture
and values and 71 just plain Biden
now we showed you last night how
criminals are terrorizing residents even
in San Francisco's upscale neighborhoods
I can say in my experience and in the
experience of people that I I know and
talk to it's clearly getting worse if
you go to like a Walgreens there's like
security guards at the front trying to
prevent people from stealing like basic
necessities
um basic necessities are like boxed up
I'm originally from Miami actually oh
Miami that's where everyone's going
that's where I'm going back next month
all right I'm done are you returning
home yes everybody's just as soon as
they graduate they go because this is
not a good place to be
and in New York under Adams Bragg and
hocal all liberals of course it's the
same story things are circling down the
drain fast
Subway crime grew 30 percent last year
compared to 2021 and extended lockdowns
destroyed kids education and in-office
work the Floyd riots where looting and
destruction went unpunished the
continuing racial animosity stoked by
the left all of it is a factor in here
it's a powder king with a fuse on top
things are so bad many residents are
afraid to take the Subway or even walk
at night well I almost got attacked by a
homeless man a couple of days ago I'm
much more aware of what's going on
around me I don't take the subway as
much it just gets worse every day I do
worry about the crime and the
homelessness and people being pushed on
the subway it's really dangerous
look eventually when the government
cannot guarantee basic Public Safety
well citizens are left to fend for
themselves
they're going to refuse to be sitting
docks which is what one Marine veteran
did in the face of a belligerent man on
a moving subway car
the passengers subdued the threatening
individual a man named Jordan Neely he
kept him down with a choke hold you can
see it here
once police arrived he was taken to the
hospital where he died
this individual had a rap sheet a mile
long 42 arrests including charges
stemming from three unprovoked assaults
on women in the subway he even
reportedly had one active warrant for an
alleged assault that happened in 2021.
now his death was tragic but it sent all
the pro-criminal left-wing loons out
there seething
this seems to me like it's an open door
to vigilantism against people who are
already vulnerable he's an ex-marine who
is trained to kill we have to hold this
individual accountable there have to be
consequences and so we'll see how this
unfolds but uh his family deserves
Justice
Alvin Bragg's office is promising a full
investigation
Al Sharpton is hoping for a manslaughter
charge and stands with protesters who
are demanding Justice for Jordan
now what about Justice for the thousands
and thousands of New Yorkers who felt
threatened over the past year by the
city's rampant crime
remember the story of Jose Alba that
Harlem Bodega owner who also refused to
be a victim
in self-defense he stabbed a man who ran
behind jumped over the store counter and
shoved him up against the wall
he was initially charged with
second-degree murder
now last July Bragg dismissed the
charges only after a loud and sustained
public outcry
but there's no justice for them and
Bragg's revolving door of arrests and
releases because thugs feel Invincible
in the Big Apple they have an upper hand
on the streets and Underground
like subway slasher Alvin Charles in
2021 after allegedly stabbing a 36 year
old teacher in the arm and stomach he
was freed on supervised released by a
liberal judge then last fall he was
arrested for stabbing Tommy Bailey a
father of three to death on the subway
bayley fought back
but it was too late
now think about the culture we're
creating here where men who jump in and
defend the defenseless are villainized
and criminals are coddled they're
deified
like George Floyd and Jordan Neely
the incentive today is when you see
someone who appears dangerous do nothing
take no action other than maybe calling
9-1-1
but what happens when you're in enclosed
space and you have no idea when Security
will actually get there
now we don't know all the facts of this
Subway Case yet but we do know this
Jordan Neely shouldn't have been on the
streets at all
and the presumption should be that a man
or a woman who is operating in good
faith when he steps in to defend himself
or others from a menacing Criminal
but the way the media are covering this
case you think the hero is the career
criminal and the 24 year old former
Marine is the thug
and the inhumanity of it you know
watching what happened with this poor
person in the subway car Jordan Neely in
New York Chokehold and murdered
basically
to say murder means that Neely's death
was an intentional Act
now that's absurd on its face
individuals who feel justifiably
threatened should be able to defend
themselves with proportional Force
that's certainly how many New Yorkers
reacted to the so-called Subway
vigilante Bernie Getz during his own
case
nobody's protecting us on the subway
I'm tired of being afraid of riding the
Subways and I have to ride the subways
if he was being about to hey
well at least mayor Adams is refusing to
jump into comment on this case since the
investigation is ongoing
let's let the D.A conduct his
investigation with the law enforcement
officials to really interfere with that
is not the right thing to do and I'm
going to be responsible and allow them
to do their job and allow them to
determine exactly what happened here now
that comment
sent flea AOC Jr into the stratosphere
she called the tragic incident a public
murder
now I didn't realize she practiced
criminal defense law between mixing
martinis
well here's the bottom line
New York City San Francisco Chicago D.C
these places are the absolute hearts of
American liberalism
and if liberalism can't work there in
any of those places some of the richest
places on the planet
then it can't work anywhere
because the streets aren't safe the
offices are sitting empty the schools
are failing and normal people are trying
to get away
so how can we be a great country when
our biggest and richest cities are dying
it's not enough to Simply throw up our
hands either and just leave New York and
other American cities to their own Fates
we can actually win this
look at what just happened in St Louis
left-wing Soros back D.A Kim Gardner
quit Good Riddance and good news
every Republican who seeks to be a
national leader has to be able to talk
convincingly about these Urban issues
about bringing our great cities back to
life
we know the Democrats are lying to the
city residents we shouldn't play the
same cynical game
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else